looks like uh somebody just stole my
vehicle heading uh
North okay did you say your
vehicle he from a vehicle 106 heading uh
South on hton street lights are still on
uh
open
what
[Applause]
and we have GPS on that
car yeah there's GPS on the
car what that number you 106 Richards
the guys running westline Richard it's a
white male blue Jack and blue
jeans 855 come up to the alley sounds
like put your hands on your
head your behind your
back I don't have a Cas
sorry some of his traffic got he's got
just some warrants and if I give him a
new what is that your
squad what the fuck that's your
squad I know wa did got
you uh someone just stole my squad West
Capital unlock
thisy I get these them we're going to
throw the I sounds
good y can't take me nowhere what are
you doing why are you wasting your time
that's that's
why's no
taking
invance